[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis weil
heute packe ich einen kleinen süßen
osterhasen das ist nämlich der hier und
meine zuschauer haben sich gewünscht
eine motiv torte ohne von doch diesmal
mit modelliert schokolade und weiße
kuvertüre und so sieht die torte aus und
ich glaube es könnte ein renner werden
genau wie die rudolf rentiert orte ja
und das ist eigentlich schon naked also
man kann nicht die torte auch mit von
dober 10 wenn man vorher eine von dort
auch bequem macht wie zum beispiel in
der garage und da hat man das außen auch
ganz schön glatt aber ich finde gerade
deswegen so echt super cool und die
ohren habe ich aus weißer kuvertüre
gemacht damit man sich später so schön
ab knapp angenommen ich weiß gar nicht
schön also man künstlern geworden da
kann man auch was verweigern oder
schokolade
dann sieht es noch sauberer aus aber ich
finds ja und inneren habe ich noch
erdbeeren mit dabei und weil es jetzt
gerade noch nicht so ganz gute frische
erdbeeren gibt habe ich die aus dem
tiefkühlfach genommen so bin ich
personal immer unabhängig jetzt stelle
ich aber zuerst einmal den teig her und
zeigt euch die zutaten für den teig
brauch ich vier eier 200 gramm zucker
etwas vanille extrakt eine prise salz
200 milliliter wasser oder eine andere
flüssigkeit 200 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl 265 gramm mehl 1 3
viertel teelöffel backpulver und 120
gramm gemahlene mandeln für den rohen
teig verrührt zuerst die eier gemeinsam
mit dem zucker vanille extrakt und dem
salz in etwa fünf bis sieben minuten
sehr cremig dann kommen die zwei
flüssigkeiten mit dazu also
sonnenblumenöl und das wasser und hier
könnt ihr gerne auch einen likör nehmen
oder auch einen saft um mehr geschmack
reinzubringen jetzt vermisse ich das
mehl gemeinsam mit dem backpulver und
den mandeln und die zutaten werden auch
nur noch kurz ein gerät
[Musik]
der teig ist jetzt vorbereitet wer
möchte kann ihn noch ein bisschen bunt
machen mit ein bisschen streute chor
[Musik]
und jetzt will ich den teig in meine
2pac ringe die habe ich bereits
vorbereitet auf 18 cm eingestellt und so
bagdad heißt dann auch richtig schön
gleichmäßig klaus du mir gerade ein paar
zucker streusel den spaß am
experimentieren und wenn hier am rand
ein bisschen was ausläuft ist gar nicht
schlimm
und so kommt datei gibt es in den
vorgeheizten backofen kann gebacken
werden und ich nutze die zwischenzeit
für ein bisschen deko für die deko
brauche ich jetzt zuerst einmal 200
gramm weiße kuvertüre und die wird jetzt
entweder fein gehackt oder ihr könnt sie
auch fein raspeln
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach den
transformer zwei drittel der kuvertüre
kommt jetzt in eine schüssel und wird
über dem wasserbad erwärmt so das sehr
schön flüssig ist jetzt ruhig noch das
restliche drittel ein
und dadurch wird die kuvertüre auf die
perfekte temperatur gebracht hat die
super fließeigenschaften und wird auch
schön fest und jetzt kann ich sie
weiterverwenden
daraus werden jetzt nämlich die ohren
gemacht um hilf mir im zimmer aufgeräumt
ok haare zur und schütze an und dann
darf mir helfen jetzt nämlich zwei
schaschlikspieß und so wie bei meiner
rentiert orte die im winter mal gemacht
habe kommuniziert drumherum die ohren
und ich könnte jetzt entweder mit einem
spritzbeutel machen oder einfach mit dem
löffel und dafür einfach die kuvertüre
darüber fließen lassen und schön in form
bringen
die ohren kommen jetzt so schon mal in
den kühlschrank die kuvertüre halte ich
jetzt kurz warm und dann wenn die ohren
fest sind kann ich sie nämlich umdrehen
und auch die rückseite noch ein bisschen
bestreichen
[Musik]
die form schon mal fertig und jetzt
nehmen wir das rest weiß und da kommt
ganz ganz kleines bisschen rosen
lebensmittel vor ein jahr reicht schon
das ist ja kommt
[Musik]
ok also hierbei können wir natürlich den
fehler machen dass man die falsche farbe
verwendet zum beispiel farben geht da
jetzt nicht und man braucht natürlich
eine farbe die sich mit der schokolade
verbindet und eignet sich die pasten
farbe ganz gut da darf man nicht so viel
nehmen
super oder passt jetzt geben wir ein
bisschen rosa noch in die ohren und dann
kommen da noch zucker streusel drauf
oder und was machen wir mit dem rest der
übrig bleibt
magst du dich um den rest kümmern
[Musik]
die eltern sind es fertig ist die kommt
in den kühlschrank und sobald der teig
abgekühlt ist geht's gleich wieder
weiter
in der zwischenzeit kümmert sich samira
darum dass das werkzeug sauber werden
[Musik]
für die torten füllung brauche ich 350
gramm tiefgefrorene ehrt werden da muss
ich gleich noch auftauen lassen etwas
zucker 5 gramm agatha und für die creme
400 gramm sahne etwas sand zu stecken
hier habe ich einen doppelnamen
frischkäse da brauche ich etwa 250 gramm
500 gramm magerquark vanille extrakt und
70 gramm puderzucker
zuerst soll ich jetzt die frucht anlage
her darf habe ich die erdbeeren wie
gesagt bereits auf trauen lassen
und da kommt jetzt zucker dazu und ihr
müsst einfach selber abschmecken wie
viel zucker ihr braucht also ich nehme
jetzt etwa 30 gramm
aber es kommt natürlich darauf an wie
süß die erdbeeren schon sind da kommt
jetzt noch das acker mit rein also die
pflanzen hersteller zähne und jetzt kann
ich die mischung aufkochen lassen und
dann muss sie zwei minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt um
die sahne steif zerschlagung mit etwas
dann abhaken
[Musik]
nach zwei minuten kann ich jetzt die
erdmasse unternehmen vom herd und füllt
sie jetzt auch um damit sie einfach ein
bisschen schneller abkühlt sie sollte so
etwa lauwarm sein also dann müsste dann
einfach schön darauf achten wer möchte
kann die masse ist vorher noch gerne
pürieren ich lasse es aber so ich möchte
einfach ein paar stückchen mit drin
haben
während es jetzt abgeht kann ich schon
mal die creme zu ende machen und zwar
nehme ich jetzt noch den frischkäse und
quark
die kommen in eine große schüssel da
puderzucker mit dazu natürlich auch
seiner partei und meine lieblingsstadt
hartmann extrakt und vanille und
erdbeeren die passen echt gut zu
erinnern und jetzt können die zutaten
einfach kurz verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier noch die sahne
unterheben und die creme dann einfach so
lange kurz kühl stellen
[Musik]
die erfüllung ist gleich abgekühlt und
wir können ja schon mal die trockenen
böden durchschneiden und das könnt ihr
entweder mit orten säge machen oder auch
mit einem brotmesser zum beispiel oder
kuchen messer und je nachdem wir denn
jedes haben möchtet könnt ihr jetzt aus
einem boden etwa drei oder auch vier
stücke schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt kann die torte gefüllt werden die
eben habe ich es grad in einem
spritzbeutel mit einer großen loch töne
damit geht nämlich ein bisserl einfacher
und dann können wir außen rum schön
gleichmäßig spazieren
[Musik]
da machen sich gerade kleine
vertiefungen rein denn da kommt die app
erfüllung ein
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der nächste boden drauf und
so fühle ich jetzt die torte bis ich
eine schöne höre bekomme
[Musik]
der letzte boden die torte kommt jetzt
in den kühlschrank für etwa zwei bis
drei stunden also die muss richtig schön
fest werden vor allem die erfüllung muss
es erst einmal fest werden
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die hasen dekoration weitermachen
und einfach sah mir ein bisschen geht es
ja schon ganz fleißig jetzt muss ich
mich mit meiner deko aber beeilen denn
so wäre es schon fast fertig mit dem
häschen nummer eins sag mal ein häschen
momentan hat es noch keine ohren aber
gleich dann gucken wir gleich okay ich
nehme jetzt zu modellieren etwas modelle
schokolade die hat 25 prozent echte
schokolade mit dabei und ist echt super
lecker und die eignet sich auch für
anfänger zu modellieren
das habe ich ein kleines weißes stück
bereits weiß geknetet und kann jetzt
einmal halbieren und nur zwei kugeln
formen
ich habe ich auch eine skizze finde ich
immer ganz gut dann weiß man nämlich was
man als letztes noch machen muss
die zwei kugeln werden jetzt
aneinandergelegt und ganz leicht flach
gedrückt die sollen schon noch schön
dreidimensional bleiben und jetzt nehme
ich ein stück rosa und phorms einfach
klein zu einer süßen kleinen nase kann
zb auch herzförmig sein
[Musik]
für die zwei füße nämlich wieder zwei
gleich große teile und formen sie wieder
erst zu einer kugel und dann werden sie
leicht flach gedrückt und jetzt nämlich
ein stumpfes messer und kann hier oben
einfach die pfoten eindrücken
das kann ich hier noch kleine rosa eine
punkte dran drücken
und beim fck noch kleine herzchen
ausstechen und die auch draufkleben
für die augen nehme ich jetzt etwas
schwarz und nehmen eine lok hülle um sie
rund auszustechen und da kommen noch
weiße lichtreflexe drauf die ich dann
aus london drauflegen
ein richtiger haase brauchen natürlich
noch hasen szene und dafür nehme ich
jetzt etwas von dampf weil der schönweiß
ist und das kann ich dann wird er mit
einem stumpfen gegenstand wegschneiden
und zuschneiden und einfach dran kleben
jetzt ist es schön kühl und ich kann sie
mit der restlichen creme schön
bestreichen
also erst oben und dann noch die seiten
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr den
hasen gerne noch mit zum beispiel
kokosflocken bestreuen oder mit
geriebener weißer schokolade
aber ich lasse ihn jetzt gerne einfach
so wir kommen jetzt an stoffe rein denn
ansonsten hält das hier gar nicht dran
bei den ohren solltet ihr darauf
aufpassen dass da steht ein bisschen
länger rausguckt also ich hoffe dass es
jetzt einfach gut hält ansonsten müsse
da wirklich vorher ein bisschen dran
denken aber wir halten auch so
und jetzt nehme ich hier noch diese deko
erdbeeren ich habe hier noch blumen also
die oblaten blumen oder auch die oblaten
rosen und damit den rechner ein bisschen
die oberfläche
für die rest decken nämlich noch ein
modell werkzeug ihr könnt aber auch
einen zahnstocher nehmen und hier
einfach so ein paar punkte noch
eindrücken
und wenn ihr möchtet nehmen sie noch die
zucker schrift und könnten auch die
barthaare machen und damit der haare
fertig
[Musik]
jetzt schneiden wir an zum anschneiden
nämlich hat oben paar blümchen wieder
weg ja ich weiß immer cool aus aber für
den anschnitt nicht ganz so praktisch
genau wie sag mal so so so was machen
die nackte wahrheit
okay weil es einfach die leute
schockiert so sagen wo ist der
denkfehler der denkt vielleicht ist da
vorne die nasa mit anschließend darum
solche leute geht hier mit was wir haben
dezember dieser slogan ist doch ist
alles gelogen haben dezember
wir haben jetzt das weihnachten gefeiert
sein kann da war nichts reißen die leute
ja was du mal nachgefragt
ja ich liebe ja jetzt dass du jetzt
zusammengebaut haben euch ja weil die
nase ist schwer und kann von dort dran
so schlimm ist nicht schlimm
[Musik]
hier noch mal was um leute zu
schockieren
was den osterhasen getragen oder intel
sonst gibt es auch hier so gut aus und
das wichtige an so konnten auch wenn es
motive ist wie auch immer der kuchen
muss schmecken und der ermahnung muss
probieren
und ja ich weiß ich weiß aber dass ich
irgendwann jetzt langweilig finde dass
man sagt das schmeckt ist einfach
langweilig ja kann ich jetzt nicht
irgendwie verbesserungswünsche oder so
äußern
vor lauter gut ich mache sonst ja was
ist also mission erfüllt der kuchen
schmeckt und ich finde ein echtes vor
allem wenn ihr wirklich an ostern ein
bisschen freier denken nur mit seiner
mama zu übernehmen auch zum opa und papa
und tante onkel egal wohin
und auch wenn ihr kein ostern feiert
dann könnt ihr dann trotzdem machen denn
da hab ich echt süß aus unserem schönen
sie ist auch frühlings haase
das rezept gerne haben möchte dann
schaut auf salehs - blog.de vorbei da
steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
freue mich schon auf eure season
osterhasen sind und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal die show batman richtig
genial
diese nämlich aufs weiße schokolade
[Gelächter]
[Musik]